merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre monsieur le Président
de la radar tout d'abord je tenais à
saluer le courage jésukrainienne et des
Ukrainiens qui depuis un an maintenant
vivent sous une menace constante et ils
ont montré au monde entier ce que
l'engagement d'un peuple à défendre son
territoire veut dire depuis février la
Russie a fait le choix de la guerre elle
a fait le choix de l'escalade et depuis
la France est aux côtés de l'Ukraine
elle est aux côtés du droit la France
est en soutien à un état voisin ami en
détresse
et il est normal que la France prenne
toute sa part en soutien à l'Ukraine
c'est ce que nous faisons depuis le
devis début de ce conflit de manière
régulière de manière appuyée de manière
suivie nous apportons un soutien
diplomatique matériel et nous affirmons
notre sincère solidarité envers le
peuple ukrainien cette aide elle est
nationale portée par l'état français
mais elle est aussi à tous les niveaux
des strates des collectivités les
communes les départements et les régions
la région Grand Est un parfait exemple
en plus de sa diplomatie en plus de son
aide humanitaire en plus de son armement
notre pays possède une réelle expertise
dont de nombreux autres domaines nous
comptons de nombreux entreprises
françaises dont les compétences peuvent
et doivent être mises au service de
cette cause il faut mobiliser nos
acteurs économiques afin de venir en
aide à la population civile ukrainienne
afin de bâtir la paix car après les
temps de guerre viennent les temps de
paix et c'est ce temps que nous appelons
de nos vœux dès maintenant il faut
identifier les besoins du peuple
ukrainien viser les secteurs
prioritaires reconstruire les
infrastructures civiles détruites qu'il
s'agisse de l'accès à l'énergie à l'eau
au secteur agroalimentaire à celui de la
santé de l'éduquer de l'éducation du
transport ainsi madame la Première
ministre mes questions sont simples
comment se positionne la France
aujourd'hui pour son intégration à
l'effort et à l'urgence de
reconstruction de l'Ukraine maintenant
mais aussi sur le long le moyen et le
long terme et comment ce
coordonne-t-elle au niveau de l'Union
européenne je vous remercie